欢迎收听古来
我是沈默公
本期节目由三生买赞助
接食品的原则
大家知道吃过好才可以接
这次三生买寄东西来挑了五样
讲几个
一口蒜味糯米肠
把香肠跟糯米包一起
大肠包小肠做成一口一个
不用切不会散
蒜香肉排
蒜味重到不用客气
肉大片又厚
而且腌好了不用再处理
椒盐胖胖翅
那个翅真的超胖
椒盐入味
不用刷酱不用顾火
皮烤脆之后配啤酒超危险
蜜汁肋排
本來以為會死田結果沒有
烤到肉直接離苦啃完手指還得舔個幾下
整箱都是這個邏輯全部醃好只要負責烤
想像一下那個畫面
炭火起來熱排放上去
蜜汁滴到炭上滋滋
旁邊的蝦子慢慢變紅
糯米腸烤到外皮有點焦
這些東西不用會做菜只要會顧火就好
其實中秋最花時間的不是烤而是採買
跑一堆地方份量抓不準
買太少尷尬買太多冰箱塞不下
三生買這次做兩個組合
試單組跟重倉烤肉組
不確定的就先試單
确定的可以直接重仓
试团组12样4-6个人
原价2045这一档1699
重仓组17样
一整箱8.5公斤10-12个人
试团组全部都有热门加倍再多5样
马来西亚白虾雪花烧肉
腹鞋猪肉条生豆包
还有一尾菩萨曼
那个曼是口糊的白曼
不是随便一条鰻鱼
要烤就要烤好的
再送你日本A5和牛
原价4225这一档3249
现整快1000
光有100多样
你自己去挑的话
可以结账输入GOY
全占九折
懶得挑就買組合
直接幫你代操
烤肉這種行情
一年只有一次
沒有回答可以等
大概就是這樣
連結在資訊欄這邊
有興趣的朋友可以去看看
組合點進去就是優惠價
不用書代碼
現在下單
中秋節前到貨
正式進入9月備賽月
我本來想法是說
大概會花9到10月的時間
要去準備11月要跑的New Balance
那也不是馬拉松
反正就是那種
10公里的小小碼之類的
我不知道那個正確的定義叫什麼
因為我從來都沒有跑過10公里
所以本來想法是
就是要靠9-10月的密集練習
那這樣子呢
可能就可以趕上在11月的時候完成比賽
那當然其實那時候去做這些規劃的時候
都還不知道說自己會去瘦了大概快10公斤
那也不知道有在做什麼功能訓練跟打網球之類的
還是那時候已經開始打網球
反正就是那時候應該都還沒有規劃到這些東西
所以本來想說兩個月的時間應該是有點緊繃
但是相信用意志力可以把它拷過去
結果非常意外的
因為本來想說9月1號開始訓練嘛剛好在禮拜天好像是8月31號的時候就講說反正也沒事下午在那邊閒閒的乾脆就去跑步好了然後就意外的一次把10公里跑完了這是我第一次直接跑到10公里
過往的話可能當兵我記得
好像是最後面考試的時候
是考3公里還是5公里
應該是3公里
然後平常是跑1500還是3公里
忘記了反正就是從來都沒有跑過這麼多
在這次的跑步訓練算是還蠻意外
竟然可以一次通過
雖然在過程之中我覺得是非常的痛苦
有搭配自己的耳機音樂
對拍子
或者說試著去看一下窗外的世界
去緩解掉無聊的感覺
我覺得跑步對我來說最困難的一點
其實是真的非常無聊
只是後來我聽一些
很會跑步的朋友跟我分享
最後面你其實會喜歡的
就是那種無聊的感覺
那可能就是冥想的感受之類的
只是你要花一點時間才會理解
所以我確實在前面的三公里的時候
我想說其實最難的
就是要撐到十公里的話
應該就是要如何去排解掉
這種無聊的心情
在那邊罵東張西網
甚至是把手機拿出來
跟朋友那邊傳訊息
還在討論說明天要買什麼東西之類的
在過程中也持續的跟一個
懂跑的朋友去追蹤
就是他目前心跳是到多少
我看大概就是150-160左右
持續到5公里
但是前面很膨脹
覺得跑步不過也是這樣子
這麼簡單
其實因為我過去的體能訓練
已經是幫我累積到
可以直接跑10K之類的
大概跑到5K之後
就可以很明顯的感受到
你不是說你的體力不夠
但是你的腳就開始酸
會很明顯開始痠
所以大概5-7K的時候
我覺得是那種進入了人生低谷的感覺
就是你會開始懷疑說
我到底可不可以跑完
然後你會想偷懶想說
反正我還有兩個月的時間
那我可能今天就先到5先到6就好
然後接下來我可能等後面幾天
再把它堆上去
可是後來轉念一想到覺得
其實我現在體力感覺是可以的
就只是腿稍微的痠一點
那不如就把它跑完
可是身體一直告訴你說
可能快不行了真的好累
然後注意到心跳就開始往上跑
什麼160 170
甚至快要到180之類的
體力可以
可是身體已經有一些地方告訴你說
我現在很累我要停下來
這時候直接開大決
我心中想的就是
幹嘛我現在停下來
列祖列宗瞧不起我
全家瞧不起 兒子瞧不起
就是告訴自己說一定要把他跑完
除非說我今天可能就直接在這邊
我就倒下 我要嘛就倒下
我只有倒下跟跑下去
這兩個結論
所以最終就莫名其妙的一路跑
跑到大概差不多快8的時候
突然間回光返照
就是5到7的時候超級累
然後到8突然間覺得
好像已經沒有感覺了
就進入那種很輕鬆很愉快的一個感受然後同時前面還會覺得無聊然後會想要換歌想要跟朋友傳訊息因為現在開始累開始噴汗了所以你已經沒有辦法做這件事情
但是你可以很專心的去
就我看著跑步機前面螢幕的反光
就是看著自己的身體在那邊跳之類的
然後看著外面的雲朵
就是你現在可以腦筋空白
前面是你一直在想要做事情
然後到後來是進入腦筋空白
可是身體卻不會累
你還是感覺到腿有一點痠
可是跟5到7的感受是不一樣
後面就蠻簡單的
一路到9到10
我覺得到10之後其實都還可以繼續跑
但是我一開始設定的時候
我就直接把它按程式
就是Target 10km
所以它到10公里
它自動就開始減速就慢下來
不然覺得其實可以繼續跑
跑的速度
我是不知道它幾分數
反正就跑步機按8
後來人家是跟他說
這好像什麼
7分半還是多少的速度
就是算是還OK啦
大概整個跑完10公里
會花的時間是一個小時
又十多分鐘左右
整體來說是一次非常好的體驗
雖然到今天就是已經是禮拜三了
我的腿都還是感覺快要爆炸了
甚至去功能訓練的時候就跟教練說
我們今天腿可能不行
這個腿真的感覺快炸開
以前可能有時候你去做一些重訓
或是功能訓練的時候
你會知道說雖然你的腿是很痠
但你是可以繼續的
現在就真的覺得說
痠到有時候連站起來都會痛之類的
教練就問我說你是痛什麼地方
我跟他說應該有點像這種膝蓋外插
他說那是韌帶
他說其實如果說你平常沒有去做
這類的訓練
你一次推上去的話
一般來講會比較鍛鍊到是韌帶
韌帶也是一個比較難鍊到的地方
但是鍊上去之後
它也是比較難掉下來的地方
所以一開始對韌帶的壓力
可能是稍微的大一點之類的
但這次的體驗是極好
我覺得可能接下來一個禮拜
就會去跑個10km這樣
只是可能前面是跑步機
我覺得後面還是要面對現實
就是要去跑外面
因為我相信在瞎的太陽
或者說那種悶熱感之下
那個感受應該是完全不一樣
因為健身房裡面是有冷氣的
所以很像作弊
但確實是蠻意外
因為以前最多可能就是3-5K
當兵的時候會這樣子跑
那也是沒有辦法就被逼的
可是在退伍之後
就從來幾乎已經沒有在什麼長跑之類的
竟然一次可以直接幹上10K
這個對我來講是非常的意外
那也意外的去激勵到自己身邊的一些朋友
我沒有要去酸人家的意思
但我身邊有一些朋友
我就看他每天都在拍線動
在那邊自拍
跟自己精神喊話說
跑3K很累或什麼
我想說感覺就超難的
因為那時候就是會看他的線動
所以想說要跑到10K
可能真的要花蠻多時間
結果就意外一次把它幹完
然後那個朋友被我激勵
因為我跟他說我一次就成功他就說媽的我們明天開始我要跑超過3K然後他也就順利的跳到5K去但是他的整個身高跟體重都是比我大隻所以相對困難一點我覺得可能自己回顧一下
認為跟減重有蠻高的一個關聯性
就是因為現在重量變形
所以算是相對輕鬆的
可以完成這一趟
心中覺得蠻高興的
就是自己的Yes Man計畫
雖然沒有像當時
就是我會對蠻多事情
就盡量say yes
然後出去走一走
但這次就想說
因為那時候已經開始有去做一些身體的改善計畫
所以覺得有朋友跟我講說
其實你去跑一些長跑是蠻不錯
我也認為說可以試看看
那就這樣跑去報名
本來想說
反正最糟的狀況就是用走的把它走完之類的
但意外應該是可以把它跑完
因為還有兩個月的時間
那第一次就可以這樣
我相信後面應該可以慢慢的拉長
至於會不會不小心跑到上頭
我覺得對我來說可能還要再花一點時間
就後面會懂
但是他其實也不敢把話說死
你就發現說很多那種30歲的人
真的就開始跑步
而且聽說跑步是一個
就是不像某一些那種比較激烈的
那種競爭型運動
就是可能你今天人
假的突破30歲的話
你就是一直往下坡走
聽說跑步的高峰
可以拉到更後面之類
所以才會有蠻多
進入中年的人可能會選擇跑步
所以說不定後面自己也會開始這樣
但總之是一次蠻意外的突破
那也在這邊給各位朋友
各位聽眾們稍微的激勵一下
如果說你有一些東西想挑戰看的話
有時候那個真的是超出你的想像
就你不知道說人的極限可以到哪
雖然我不知道說我這次可以這樣衝完
跟我拿獵主獵終
還有我兒子會瞧不起我威脅自己
有沒有關係我不曉得
但總之就是把它幹完了
就是真的是超出自己的預期
竟然可以這樣子跑完
你想都沒有想過
所以確實是一個蠻好的體驗
在這邊稍微的分享一下自己的心得
接下來我們來進入市場話題
像它這個盤面我覺得就還是差不多
就是維持一個震盪的模式
自己身邊比較動能的朋友
就整天都在罵
就覺得這個盤子他媽有夠垃圾的
可是我自己是認為從8月到現在盤面
真的是很還好
我覺得它算是一個好做的
反正你就是hold著你不要動
然後它鏡子就越墊越高
然後你距離你可以收復的高點就越來越近了
我至今是還沒有收復7月最瘋狂那時候的一個高點
好像還有一小段距離
但是已經持續的追上
沒有意外的話搞不好再下個月或是下下個月
好像這樣好像再差一個flag
就感覺應該是有機會可以再次的創新高
本來其實在7月這樣的重殺
你知道直接從高檔滴滴下來30%
我心中想的是
這可能要到年底才有辦法救回來了
沒有想到可以在後面有這些暴力的反彈
跟一些族群人都相對都掌握到
雖然沒有掌握到醉噴的東西
就大家心中已經想說
媽的早知道我滿手大力光加
浴金光我就發了
對 但人生是沒有這種
後悔藥或是說水晶球的
就算你可能有買到這些東西
像自己是有買到
只是你不可能買多
那就是配置的其中一環
你就想說早知道我壓多一點的話
我就可以上去的更快
所以它確實是有東西持續的跑
然後像光通相關的股票
其實也都是持續的強勢
總之已經算是超出自己的預期很多
因為本來也算是預期偏低
就認為其實上半年真的是過太爽了
然後後來吃一個天法
後面修復要時間
沒有想到修復了這麼快
其實以大盤的角度來講
就是已經在新高附近了
所以真的就差一點
但他就是很牛皮
反正就上去然後又再掉回來
然後再休息再狠一下
搞不好後面再繼續上去
所以我覺得只要不要一直想要去幹動
你就沒問題
當然講是很簡單
我在日本沒有什麼感受的原因之為
就是你就是在外面旅遊
所以你的東西打得上一點
你也不會一直想要盯盤
但是一回台灣
馬上就會把東西稍微集中
就要去找東西搞
就會開始感受到這個盤
它真的蠻磨人的
但確實是把自己拉出來看
就會知道你7月已經是對這個
下半年沒有任何的信心了
現在竟然可以這樣子爬回來
其實已經算是非常的感恩展叹
市場還是有蠻多新的故事持續發生
我們有在節目跟大家更新
最新的一個議題
就是在聯發課之別人是獲得了
揮答跟Alphabet
或是一些策略夥伴的投資
它藉由的管道是ECB
就是它的可轉載
這個是回答第一次投資台灣上市公司
然後第一次出手
就是史上最大的ECB
數字是35億美元
Google我是不知道說
它到底是拿到多少份額
可是絕大多數的份額
就是被回答給拿走
這筆錢的目的是什麼
就是一個策略夥伴的合作
當然它一定也有
有可能部分成分的
Seller Finances的味道
因為畢竟可能在MTK這邊
我們知道在銅鑼有一個Data Center
他們應該也是會去採購NVIDIA的東西
但是我認為兩派公司所說的說法是對的
它就是一個長遠夥伴的合作
認識這麼久
其實聯發科本身就是一個財務健全
也很賺錢的公司
所以並不像是可能
NVIDIA去投一些相對比較新的公司
會給人家去質疑說
這個是不是賣方去做融資
是不是自己在那邊自體循環
這個我覺得就是有一定程度的差異
所以可以把它視為說
就是一種那種差期的意思
那當然Alphabet
因為它本身就是聯發科的一個客戶現在我們都知道說它的TPU的V8T這一顆是在聯發科這邊去做一個
就算是聯發科第一次幫我們設計TPU
後來再走到後面的Humufish
之後的一些Role Map
其實都已經有相當程度的雛形了
所以客戶也有建壓卡位
所以他有點像說可能聯發科有一些目的
他搞不好是要拿去做一些什麼設備的建置
廠房或是有一些擴大投資
要跟市場調錢
只是說就是被像是NVIDIA
或是Alphabet這些
同時是一些夥伴跟客戶的人
那就把絕大多數的份額是給他拿走
這個東西他們圖了是什麼
當然絕對不會是票息
票息是0%
付出的大概是10幾%的一個溢價
這要什麼
它其實就是一個選擇權的意思
它要的東西是什麼
它要的是如果說XPU成功的話
在聯發哥這邊的發展是OK
股價上漲
它就會相當程度可以轉換出股份
所以整體看下來是一個
我覺得蠻不錯的消息
當然在前陣子也有一個類似的消息
應該不會說前陣子
可能是幾年前的
就是那時候應該有在追
IC Design相關新聞都知道
事情有拿到Amazon的一個投資
然後大家看到傑夫貝佐斯先生
我看到想說這一定是超屌
但我記得好像就連拉都沒有拉
好像只是一個開高
然後後來就下來
沒有記錯的話是這樣子
這次聯發可能有直接送一根漲停
當然像今天就是有回到平盤了
所以就是一根漲停的一個消息機靈
也算是蠻不錯的
我們就稍微再聊一下說
我們覺得這個合作會是什麼樣的一個形式
他們大概也是在玩什麼樣的一個遊戲
當然其實聯發科跟NVIDIA
已經是長期算是合作夥伴了
他們有在蠻多情境之下
都是有一起在做事情
所以他並不是說在這之前
他們是沒有什麼合作經驗
像之前跟大家分享N1X
就是他那個筆電的晶片
它就是NVIDIA GPU加聯發科的SoC
外加可能在車用座倉或是一些
可能在相關業務的一些合作
這個都是持續一直有在進行
只是現在升級成為是NVIDIA的AI Platform
然後再加上可能聯發科的客製XPU
這個東西去把它做一個更深度的綁定
大家看到Google也有進來
可能會想說這個合作跟Google有沒有什麼關係
先講我自己的結論
我猜可能跟Google的關係不大
他們是兩個獨立事件
反正聯發哥就發了ECB
然後就是兩個大咖跑來認
兩個大咖認的理由並不是說
他們三方要結盟桃源三結義我覺得不是這樣的一個情形當然一定還是有相當程度的合作因為像Google算是自己在推自己的TPU可是也是NVIDIA很大的一個買家嘛還是買了很多GPGPU
那在聯發客這邊呢
在他們自己內部的一些算力的使用上
就我們了解後來的建制
也是會去使用NVIDIA的Rack
所以大家算是那種千絲萬縷的關係啊
可是他不是說那種有目的性的
把三個人弄在一起
那甚至可以講成說
目前在像NVLink或是NVIDIA的
各種interconnect
可以算是最大的對手就是Google的ICI
然後跟他的OCS
就是他ICI互聯
然後跟他的光交換機
目前可能市場上就是在NVIDIA的Solution以外
最強大的一個玩家之一
所以他應該不會想要去整個更加深入的綁入在這個生態系裡面
所以我會把它去視為是兩個獨立的事情
那只是他們同時發生
大家都想要來MTK這邊去稍微的分一杯羹
在回答這邊他想要的東西是什麼
我覺得就算他應該是沒有辦法在這個案子裡面
然後獲得Google太多的一個額外認同
或是說一些採購
但是他在讀的東西應該是
MTK在特別是Google給他資源去練兵之後
後面有可能在整個XPU的市場裡面會持續的拉高
當今天XPU持續拉高
大家第一個想像就是
受害的可能就是GPGPU
像是NVIDIA或是AMD這類的業者
沒錯他們的市場會被吃掉
但我們剛好在前幾集有提到說
其實TAM會增加
所以本來一個東西持續而蓬勃發展
你就很難想像說只有少數的廠家
會把所有東西吃掉
因為這樣大家都沒有辦法玩下去
所以本來就是一些本來有Dominion地位
像可能最早是OpenAI
在AI算是一個完全的壟斷
幾乎啦
然後後來就是市場就開始被一些人拿走
甚至下可能聲量最高的變成是Antropic
所以它是一個正常發展的現象
只是我覺得NVIDIA它要的東西是更廣
他們也意識到這件事情
他們也知道說沒有辦法去阻止客人
不要去開發XPU
雖然有一些小暗示
就是它很常在一些電話會議或訪問裡面
它不會明說
因為我覺得像Jensen它本身就是一個AI的
有點像說教主等級的東西
所以它不可能去採別人的商品
這個看起來是非常low的事情
但是它會有蠻多的
我真的認為就像是暗示的
就是告訴大家說那個產品線
你那個後面這樣推可能會很辛苦
我們這東西算下來的最便宜
買越多神越多之類
他還是一直釋出這樣的訊號
但是客人沒有辦法
就還是會想要去做一些有主控權的事情
把一些XPU拉回來自己開發
沒關係嘛因為黃文鑫有跟大家說現在一座AI工廠他要的是七種的揮搭晶片XPU只是其中的一部分其他的環節 NVIDIA也都是有角色可以進來扮演
所以我記得好像在今年3月
他有一個投影片有放出來
就是在NVLINK這邊我們都知道說
反正就是NVL72
然後跟後面會再持續攔上去的
他最主軸的一個AI伺服器Compute Rack之外
接下來他們有MGX ETL Rack
這些東西他就算是可以去跟XPU做結合的東西
包含像是GRUG3
Vera CPU Rack
或是Blue Fill 4 STX Storage Rack
跟Spectrum的 Rack
所以這些東西他本質上是可以去讓客人的XPU來跟他做結合
所以雖然以前在資料中心的建置上面
大家的認知是反正你就是跟NVIDIA買他整套的東西都給你
客人他們既然要去轉XPU的話
沒關係在周圍附帶的東西
其實你還是可以跟我的東西
去做一個深度的綁定
這樣子的話
就算你要去走自己的XPU
我可能也可以在裡面獲得
蠻多的吃肉和糖的機會了
所以它圖的算盤應該是這樣子
只是就像我們前面所講的
應該在Google可能是相對
會比較難進去
因為他們算是自己有蠻完整的互聯的解方
但其他未來的客人
也就是有機會走的模式是
雖然他們自己去設計XPU
透過MediaTag
但是可能裡面會去使用到NVIDIA Fusion
去搭配NVIDIA的MGX ETL RECS
不管是去做存儲或是網通連結相關
這樣子
回答還是可以在裡面獲得非常多的一個價值
所以它現在有一點像是從本來的賣GPU
然後變成是賣Total Solution
如果說有一塊東西你想要自己去做的話
沒有關係我也不會去阻擋你
可是你其他東西可能是可以用我的
所以它變成是一個那種
萬能雜貨店的感覺
去跟MediaTag做這樣子連結
我覺得它圖的就是未來的客人
有機會可以走這一條路線
在MediaTag的一個成功案例之中
順便的去推廣
回答在周圍的一些Solution
再來在回答這邊
他們有一個東西叫做NVHBM
NVHBM是什麼呢
在官方的宣稱講說
它比HBM4E的頻寬再多了30%
功耗是少了15%
還額外再多給你晶片的面積
他是去把Controller從本來的Accelerator
搬到現在HBM的Base袋裡面
但是他跟本來的東西最大的差
就是本來是走JEDEC的一個規格
然後現在變得有點像是說
NVIDIA自己的一個特規
我覺得也有在為這個東西佈局的意思
就是NVHBM
如果說在後面可以取得
相當程度的一個試占的話
當然他們就是從記憶體的廠商身上
去獲得一些價值
記憶體廠商偶爾你可以說是台積電的
身上會額外再獲得一些價值
為什麼這樣說
因為本來的HBM
那個Base Die
像可能SK Hynix或是Samsung
Sansung應該是後面還是會自己做
SK Hynix在HBM4之後
應該就是把BaseDive會交給台積電去做
美光的話就我們的理解
因為前面可能沒有辦法
滿足NVIDIA的一個要求
所以後來也是直接把BaseDive去丟給TSM去做
你說如果今天
就來說像聯發科協助去設計開發
然後採用了NVHBM的話
會交給誰設計
他應該就不會是給記憶體三大廠
應該還是交給台積電去做
只是可能NVIDIA
也可以在記憶體這邊去Capture到一些額外的價值
但這個東西我們可能還要再等一段時間再去做驗證
因為我們知道其實NV在過去
它持續推出很多又新又酷的東西
有些東西可能看起來一段時間會
好像就雷聲大語很小
像那時候的CPX-REC
但最近郭明琦又寫一篇文章說
他看到CPX-REC又復活了
本來大家以為說不見了
prefile那一塊都不見了
然後現在又再一次跑出來
所以NVHBM可以稍微的去觀察一下
但我覺得NVIDIA的這次跟MediaTek
相關的投資跟合作
我覺得也是有想要把這個東西
鋪出去的一個意思
所以稍微的把自己的看法去做一個總結
就是它是另外一次的綁裝行為
那它應該不能夠很簡單的去解釋
成為Seller Finances
不一定這樣子
因為本身MediaTek它就已經有
很完整的收入
它是很健全的公司
所以它不像有一些那種算力租賓公司
真的有點像是
他幫NVIDIA去收一些庫存
當一個中轉廠
如果他沒有NVIDIA這些投資
可能就連生意都很難做
可是MediaTag不是這樣的一個狀況
所以單純的就把它當成是一個
夥伴之間的生化合作
因為前面有RTX Spark
然後筆電
N1X 3奈米
然後後來現在又再多NVIDIA Fusion XPU
所以它就是一個更加深入的合作
只是我們的一個觀察重點就是
到底後面的客戶會是誰
具體的tap out會是什麼時間
再來就是NVHBM的記憶體會造成什麼樣的一些額外的影響會不會透過這些IC Design方更快的鋪出去這個就是一些觀察的重點
以整個大格局來說
目前看起來NVIDIA已經是把市面上所有的玩家都已經納入灰下了
他跟像是四星、發哥
或者是像是Marvel最近也有一些劇情的產生
其實幾乎每個都已經是被他攔住
都已經是加入它的行列了
現在就很好奇說
Broadcom會不會有照一句
你不能說完全的去加入它
可是就是額外再開一條線
不是只有自己的fabric
可能也會去使用NV相關的那些solution
這個是後面可以期待的
但目前看下來就是
它在想要吃的肉
其實也是博通的肉
要再一次要再去採博通的感覺
所以真的就是最近的一些消息
看起來都是
大家要在博通身上去吃肉的感覺
你知道說這家公司
有多強的一個競爭力
大家想要拆東西
都要從他身上踩出來
當然博通很快就會出來講話了
我相信這次Hawk應該就會火力全開
因為現在外面確實是蠻多對他的不看好
不然說像我們去分析一些事件
我們也會去提到說
可能對博通的影響是比較大的
因為大家要去挑戰博通
但是這不代表博通就一定會掉一些東西之類的
因為你要知道
像我們前面才剛剛提到說Harlapenil
它做出來是一個超級強大的晶片
所以就證明了博通它的設計跟統整能力
一定是非常強大
雖然這件事情還是有一點眾說紛紜
因為像有一派的說法是說
OpenAI其實他們用了AI去協助設計這個晶片
所以這個晶片會這麼強
其實跟OpenAI有很大的關係
我覺得不一定
我覺得可能還是跟博通有非常深度的know how
有很大的一個關係
所以這可能就要等到在博通的電話會議之後
我們來觀察他們針對這些事件有什麼回復
雖然一下未看先拆就知道說他一定開始屌噴
然後一定會再次強調自己的競爭利益之類的
但是我覺得從他的回應就可以更加全面的去了解
在過去一段時間市場發生的這一些事情
到底實際上在大家的互相進和
會發生什麼樣的一個狀況
可是先講結論
我認為它還是會有點類似
就前陣子的光銅之爭
那時候確實是銅相關的類股
直接被打到爆掉
如果你用股價的角度來看的話
確實你從它的營收去看
它是沒有被打掉的
它還是持續的有開出來
最終股價是也還公道
就是那時候被打下去的同類股
後來一堆都新高了
只是那時候被打得很慘
然後市場都說它不行
我覺得有點類似這樣的一個情形
因為它市場就是有點偏向是
我覺得很偏執就是當大家知道說有某個新東西可能會出來那就會很直覺認為說舊東西就會被chaallenge就會白掉抑或是像我們前面提到HBM在後面會有很多降規相關的討論
12high基本上高隆的在後面就比較不會看到
短期內往8high或甚至往4high的方向去
理論上其實對整個記憶體的供應
它會怎麼說
它有辦法賣更多
我覺得其實整體來說
對市場也是一個蠻健康的事情
但那時候就是有一些
像以前外資的朋友會去提醒說
基本上市場裡面的一些法人
他們不一定會吊這件事情
他不會吊說
其實這個對大家來講
就類似我們講的光銅
它其實可以並存 大家都會好
他們不管
他今天看到dispack
他就先sell
他就把你sell爆掉
所以其實我們要擔心的就是
怎麼講
不是公司本身
會不會在這些競爭
或是新發生的各種策略聯盟裡面
有些人可能會受害
或是什麼受益之類
不一定要去講這種
就是偏產業或是中廠的東西
就是說其實在短線上
特別是我們畢竟還是在市場工作人
我們就會知道說有些東西
就是事件一丟出來
這個市場一定會有所反應
那有時候反應的幅度會蠻大
雖然很多時候你到最後回頭看就發現說
根本就是沒事
但其實有波動就會有行情
也會有一些機會
也可能會有一些傷害
但總之就是要去習慣這些波動
但是我認為長遠來看
因為現在AI真的是在
我覺得不用去吵說是幾局下半
反正就是還是很前面
就一定還是很前面
所以那個市場可能是大到超過大家想像
就大家應該都會在裡面受惠
那只是在過程之中會怎麼樣演
會怎麼樣波動
那個不是這麼的確定
所以我們大概跟大家講一下
自己在這些事件裡面的一些想法
那我認為等到博通去做回應之後
就可以非常完整的知道說
OK 那現在大家的態度是怎麼樣
但目前初步看
就是跟MARVIA
或者說現在跑去MTK要綁裝
或什麼的就是
每個人想要的東西
感覺都是要從博通身上去搶一點東西的感覺
那其實大家都互相啦
就像是XPU
他們每次想從會打身上搶一點東西
但最終可能大家都是越吃越多越吃越飽
你不要去很聚焦在
什麼市占率開始掉
什麼出貨的科數
就像現在ASIC出貨科數一定會越來越高
可是不代表NVIDIA要越賺越少
因為市場是持續的在變大
大概是這樣的一個情形
接下來我們來進入Q的部分
第一位Lexy
安安夢恭
我是第二集就收聽的聽眾
9月3號是我弟弟林博的生日
想請您幫我助他早日喜貨靈兒
謝謝他股票賺錢要請我吃何點壽司
幫我謝謝男友Damniel
怎麼是這麼奇怪的名字
Damniel是啥小
可以不用念我沒有打錯
還沒結婚前都是Damniel請我吃Smith & Walensky牛排甘氏樂也蠻好吃的想請問會點什麼配菜或是前菜祝您全家平安健康幸福
希望弟弟可以喜貨鄰兒
再來講說會點什麼配菜跟前菜
這叫烤培根嗎
還是烤培根是美國很有名的
才有烤培根忘記了
但如果有烤培根
牛排館的烤培根
我不知道發生什麼事情
但是都很好吃
再來的話
它有一個Mac and Cheese
超級好吃
本來我們點這個是想說
就是給一起去的小朋友吃的
後來大人吃了也都覺得非常喜歡
再來
可能也可以點個生蠔吧
我覺得那邊的生蠔也蠻不錯的
我覺得Smith & Walensky
真的是一個蠻好吃的餐點
大概這樣
下面一位
Romer
拍謝啦一直留不到
嗨嗨主委您好
想請您用不同的語氣說
節目六年啦
六年啦
我覺得我常常給
這傻小
以後不要再叫我做這種事情
祝福主委節目長紅
那另外我想祝安南
陈浩南
威里基教大爆社
Ted the moon
长虹K到天上去
谢谢主任
也谢谢G5的守护神
克诺曼
幸福快乐
我们知道幸福快乐
下面一位
Chan
有点长
但还是念一下
因为感觉是
有智男生
有苦说不出
孟公您好
开头先祝全家平安顺行
想借由节目跟您分享
遇到荡森前男友的故事
各位有瓜可以吃了
保险套说要轮流买男女平等
我疫情确诊
第一时间叫拿保险金请他吃大餐
明明是中油总公司的职员
行为非常的穷酸
还有一件最严重的事情
我跟朋友聊天时不小心说出
他解宗教信仰的事情
他给了我三个惩罚选项让我选
我选到最烂的
就是在他的租屋处罚贵三个小时
还有诸多超不合理的破事
我自己也有错
因为是我弟任男友
所以我被爱蒙蔽双眼
直到发生罚贵的事情
以及爱消磨完了才把他甩了
分手后简直重获新生
前途光明
想跟您说
如果未来有女儿一定要好好保护他
也要教他好好保护自己
我想跟您分享
是因为垃圾前男友是您的听众
想请您用最激发的语气跟他说
You're a fucking loser
孤老终生一辈子不要再期待友人爱
奇怪
这种应该不会是我们的听众吧
先讲我们这边先做一个切割
然后首先
像最近又有一个快乐宝贝
问我说是不是在flash上面
什么邀请大家加他的朋友
什么收会员
我就直接开枪
我觉得说
什麼這種白癡可以不要聽我節目
我們這邊是反對白癡的好不好
如果你是那種看到FREDS上面說
什麼謝夢公
古埃要召會員
你會有一絲絲的覺得
他搞不好真的要召人的
你趕快滾 不要聽了
直接把這個節目關掉
然後再來說
如果你是那種超級小氣巴拉
然後跟這種很莫名其妙的人
也是趕快離開啦
因為我覺得這個出去不知道
就大家會覺得說
你知道就假設我今天是跟你婚友會上面看到
然後你跟我說你喜歡聽古埃
然後接著你展現的個性是這樣子
我覺得你這在幫我調音得子
好像說怎樣嘛
所以這個人他一定有問題
然後才會有你們這些他媽有問題
但其實老實講大家要知道公允一點
就是一個林子大了什麼鳥都有
我們有40萬的亭種
所以當然裡面就是各式各樣的人會有
後來知道說
因為我40萬是看我們後台的一個統計
後來有時候就商工廠說
Spotify沒有統計在裡面
所以其實應該會是更多
所以你就想40萬
但是一個場館都裝不下
要裝好幾個場館才裝得下的人
所以裝得下
反正就是一定有很多人
很遺憾你會遇到這種
我覺得奇怪
然後外交說我單聽你的說法
會覺得說這個人是他媽有病的一個
男生啊
那這個男生如果聽眾的話
我覺得你以後不要再這樣子
雖然我知道我這樣講完
你應該下一集你會很想要留言
就你一定有你的話要說
你知道其實後來發現
感情就是這樣子啦
然後就是真的要罵
就像前面有一個聽眾離婚一樣
然後他說那個男的離婚超小氣的
什麼跟他要的東西差小
我就說因為你撕破臉之後就是這樣子
就大家會互相去結床吧
所以我們也知道說
在過往發生過很多次嘛
先有AA跑到社群上面去攻審另外一個人
然後最後面就整個反過來
我也不知道要去各打五十大板
我的意思是說
因為畢竟我先幫你湊幹他一頓的
可是他一定有他的話要說
那我不希望變成是分手類
還是你們其實很希望
我相信一定很多人希望說
男朋友也上來
然後大家在那邊互幹
對但我們就是這樣是
走一個平和的路線
那希望說就不要想太多了
有時候就只是不適合
搞不好有些人就喜歡這種play之類的
叫他穿橡膠衣
乖愛衣地上牽狗臉
搞不好有些人喜歡這種play
那就是你不適合
那至少你現在離開嘛
離開就沒事
所以這是一個自由的世界
記得離開就沒事
蠻多人會困住就是
他無法想像
或者是說沒有自信
或者甚至自信是被人家打到
他就是真的覺得說
他不只得遇到更好的
但其實世界上人這麼多
你一定會找到更好的
好大概是這樣
下面一位
加入光光 安淡無光
有一群阿飄在耳邊一直講話
猜一個植物
鬼爭吵
8分
8分他自己寫的
這個3分
2分
1分
好 夢宮祝贛安
想問安哥
目前有學會新的技能嗎
另外小弟最近在轉換工作想問夢公去把聲音的關音大會保佑我好的主管跟mentor我願意捐一個月的薪水分三期給家福等慈善團體
最後祝夢宮祝賀全家平安健康
所以這位兄弟是
因為他前面講說加入光光暗淡無光
是從最近很熱門的公司離開
要換新公司的是嗎
希望你可以順利的遇到好的主管跟mentor
然後再講說
安哥最近有什麼新的技能
就爸爸
爸爸
大家沒看好就爸爸
我覺得蠻高興的
然後再來就是
安哥有一個比較不好的習慣
就是他的炸自己
他會去吃水果
然後接著就是把汁吃掉之後
把所有的殘渣吐出來
那這個比較麻煩一點
但最近開始發現說
他會把東西吞下去
所以我們覺得非常的開心
不然每次他吃水果
都會搞得像是他媽的命案現場一樣
要不是他長得可愛
早就他媽再去山上了
所以看到孩子長大是還滿開心的
他最近就是越來越會講話了
那晚上有時候會突然間爆哭
因為在長牙齒
非常的不舒服
那下面一位
N 請問紙片人加碼問題
突然間被叫紙片人覺得怪怪的
他說看對加碼一直漲
你們會一直敢加
是加到預期的目標價嗎
又有說過一直漲到超過資金的規劃
反而會一直減碼持股
不知道加碼時機
有時候起漲沒加
後來加在反轉點
因為不知道會走多遠
夢工腹肌漏出來了
目前4塊
就是4塊
只是還沒有辦法再讓其他的跑出來
但我相信我家提值應該到滿低
下次有空去量一下
然後再來講說加碼的問題
其實我們比較少去設目標價
我覺得可能幾年前很常會聽到
人家講說什麼目標價
那個誰說什麼會到多少
但這些年越來越少聽到
因為我覺得大家真的去認識到
AI真的是非常的狂
你真的沒有必要去設定目標價
一堆東西會漲到超出你的想像
五倍十倍的都一大堆
那所以越來越少聽到就是這樣講
我自己本身就不是一個目標價的信奉者
我只是會大概去做一個參考
我覺得來說像最近大力光噴到7000多
你就大概知道說他是明年後年的幾個倍數
這個我知道
可是我也不認為說
到這個倍數它就要停
因為它搞不好可以在G1網上
這個很難說
但你心中會有一把尺
會大概可以去做一個參考
到底會是選擇一路加到
超出資金的規劃
或是會反而要去減嗎
這個都非常的看狀況
其實大家每次問這種問題
會覺得說超難跟大家講為什麼
用一個最簡單的舉例就好了
你去對兩個女生
一個長相是你喜歡的
一個長相就是你沒那麼喜歡的
你的態度會一樣嗎
如果你跟我說會一樣的
我就知道說OK那你是gay
類似這樣
所以我沒有辦法告訴大家說一個股票我們到底該怎麼樣去面對它那個真的都是不一樣的心情就像為什麼有些股票你可以接受它已經trade到可能不知道
2028 2029去了
2028 2029然後還trade在30倍
你還是可以買它
那可是為什麼另外一個股票
它看今年的本益比都只有10倍而已
為什麼你不買它
就很難講啊
這個真的很難去做解釋
我整個說就是每個人都會有心中的一把尺
然後跟你會用你過往的行為慣性
跟你是怎麼樣賺錢的
你就會持續的去把它
在基礎上面去做一個疊加
所以他會講說
可能隨著每個人出身的點位不一樣
會對股票有完全不一樣的一個看法
說不定之後AI泡沫爆掉之後
後來的一陣子大家會講說
千萬不要買本夢比的股票
可是如果說你都不去買本夢比的股票的話
其實從AI的起步至今
你應該每次買東西都是買在最高點
就算是最早那些OEM ODM
根本就營收開不出來
獲利還沒出來的時候
股價都先噴
早就先噴完
然後等他開始開營收獲利的時候
你看是不是每個都在橫盤
你就不會動了
現在光通也是很多噴到
大家講說殺小
看那個開什麼垃圾字節
可是等到他開字節
你看得懂的時候
說不定也噴完了
你懂我意思嗎
所以這個很難講
但一般來說
我們確實會用價格
去作為一個蠻核心的輔助
就是如果說你是把題材
跟動能交易作為核心的話
如果你是價值投資
作為核心的話
理論上
你會再越來越漲會越來越減
你不會越買越多
除非你都覺得說這邊都還是很便宜
那是例外
但你覺得說他都已經噴什麼三倍五倍
你怎麼可能還持續加碼
但如果你今天站在動能跟題材角度的話
你還真的會持續加碼
所以我覺得那個就是
你用的一個模型不一樣
你就會得出完全不一樣的結論
所以在我自己的經驗是
我比較喜歡去做看對價
可能在美股這邊我會做的是
我加到某一個上限
我就不去做加碼了
這個上限可能是設定
總部位的三層之類的
就是你初始可能一個部位
就是10% 15%就很多了
最多你願意可以讓它到三層或是四層
到這邊你就不敢再多了
為什麼 因為美股的經驗告訴我們就是
每次開什麼電話會議
直接一個晚上給你崩20%的
一大堆都這樣子
所以你會擔心說空手而回嗎
或是給人家幹到之類的
所以提早先去做一些封控
去做一些減碼
越漲越減
讓它壓在固定的%數
這個在美國是這樣做
那在台股我很少這樣做是因為我覺得台股的機制因為畢竟它有一個跌停然後再來就是台股本身我覺得沒有像美股這麼狂氣所以我比較願意去你一個部位再給我拉到更大
我可能都OK
我只要確定流動性是OK的就好
所以我就不會太在意說
一個部位是多少
我只在意我的部位可不可以進出
在美股這邊
因為美國市場太大了
所以你不會在意你的部位可不可以進出
因為基本上都一定進得來出的去這樣
只是你會擔心說可能被暗算到
所以就不會買到太多
所以那個跟市場別又有關係
所以它總共有很多個變因指標
一個就是它到底是什麼樣類型的股票
它是本夢比的還是本意比的
很奇怪的是本夢比的
我反而願意會一直買
本意比的如果今天脫離太遠
我就會覺得這個東西
我自己要小心一點
然後慣性是這樣
美國跟台灣市場比起來的話
美國市場就是買到某個上千
就不敢再買了
因為太多次電話會被修理了
可是在台灣市場的話
就會願意一直買
只要流動性出的掉都沒問題
反正隨時可以一鍵清倉的話
或者說你在五檔十檔內
重複丟個幾次可以丟光
沒有什麼太大的問題
所以這個也是要看狀況
只能夠大概給你一個感覺
沒有辦法給你一個絕對的答案
給你一個感覺你可以去思考一下
下面一位
Ray
安安老公想問你會買iPhone 18折疊還是Pro Max
還有你以前玩魔術世界
玩什麼職業求分享當年的心得
今年是一定會買一個折疊劑來玩看看
但是也有可能說
折疊劑玩一玩不喜歡
然後還是再去買一個Pro Max
是有機會這樣
但一般就是每年都會去買一支新的
舊的就會給家人持續的去做使用
我的目的就只是
我覺得一支手機幾萬塊
但是我玩一玩我可能有靈感
在投資裡面找到機會
那個都是很容易就回本
所以就是一定會持續跟這些最新的東西
甚至是到越後期跟得越勤
就覺得這種是很小的一個投資
再來講說以前玩魔鬥世界是玩什麼職業
素士獵人
然後再來玩惡魔獵人當坦
什麼樣的心得
我就覺得說有時候還是會蠻懷念
就是以前那種可能國小國中
在那邊打魔獸世界
還是應該是國中
我記得應該是國中
的一個那種
就是沒日沒夜跟上班一樣的一個感受
現在已經沒有辦法回到那時候了
就那時候其實去玩魔獸世界
真的有點像是在上班
就你們工會要幹嘛
你們要打副本或什麼的
那個就是大家要在線上
然後真的是沒日沒夜在那邊弄
超級累
或是像我之前很想要去蹲時光流逝圓融
必須要花非常多時間每天在那邊掛網
然後去用一些那種小gatch去提醒自己
時間到來會叫了
把你叫起床
然後去看說
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕